EU finance ministers meeting today in  Brussels discuss the Commission's plan  to establish a European fun for  strategic investments the fund would be  managed by the European Investment Bank  and would channel at least three hundred  and fifteen billion euros to projects  with the potential to create new jobs  and growth in Europe in the light of the  recent attacks in France ministers  discussed also how to starve terrorist  groups of financial resources but one  should counsel to do it today endorsed  anti-money-laundering package that  expected formal adoption of the package  is a cornerstone in our fight against  terrorism funding it is a important step  in increasing the efficiency of this on  a taxation level Minister strengthen the  rules to prevent international companies  from not paying taxes in any member  state finally ministers agreed on the  need to keep the financial assistance to  Ukraine